mit dem projekt deep hat die nasa
wirklich sensationelles vor kleine
sonnen sollen mit hilfe von
laserstrahlen extrem beschleunigt werden
und ins nächste sternensystem geschickt
werden
aber nicht nur das die mine raumschiffe
werden auch bemannt sein jetzt sind
tatsächlich die ersten passagiere für
diese interstellare reise gefunden und
die sind selbst ein bisschen
außerirdische welche lebensform es sich
dabei handelt was durch sie erforscht
werden soll und alles weitere zu diesem
spannenden nasa projekt jetzt endlich
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
die schiffe sollen mit lasern
angetrieben werden und damit extrem
beschleunigt werden und trotz dieser
hohen beschleunigung wird ihre reise zu
unserem nachbar sonnensystem wohl über
20 jahre dauert seit rund 18 jahren
tüftelt ein forschungsteam von der
university of california santa barbara
an dem nasa projekt namens deep jetzt
wurde öffentlich dass wohl passagiere
diese interstellare reise antreten
werden schon ihre namen klingen
irgendwie außerirdisch nematoden und
tardi geraten vielleicht haben einige
von euch diesen namen schon einmal im
biologieunterricht aufgeschnappt die
nematoden km/h petit es elegant sind
tatsächlich beliebte modell organismen
im fachbereich genetik die fadenwürmer
sind nur einen millimeter lange haben
dafür aber wirklich einige unglaubliche
talente beispielsweise sind sie in der
lage in dauer larven stadium mehrere
monate zu überleben ganz ohne futter
sehr viel krasser noch sind die zweiten
wohl zukünftigen nasa passagiere die ta
vie geraden auch als wassertiere oder
bärtierchen bekannt und die haben quasi
sogar schon diverse job erfahrungen
gesammelt ohne schutz im luftleeren raum
wurden sie bereits in die kälte und
strahlung des alls geschickt und sie
haben überlebt waren sind die perfekten
kandidaten also die fragestellung des
nasa projektes lautet kannte restliches
leben wie wir es kennen im
interstellaren raum existieren doch das
erste problem für die außerirdischen
passagiere wird ja schon die anfahrt
sein denn wie gesagt wird die reise wohl
20 jahre dauern das forschungsteam hat
aber auch davor schon einen plan am
start die tiere sollen in
der straße ist also eine art starre oder
ruhezustand gelegt werden und dann
regelmäßig aufgeweckt werden so könnte
überprüft werden wie die passagiere mit
den gegebenen umweltbedingungen klar
kommen wann die große reise losgeht
steht übrigens noch in den sternen der
chefentwickler findet blumen hat letztes
jahr in einem technology review
interview gesagt dass er nicht glaubt
dass er die ankunft seiner mini
raumschiff noch erleben wird zitat ich
bin jetzt 63 jahre alt und werde
vielleicht noch den start einer
interstellaren sonne in 30 jahren
erleben doch dann wird es noch einmal 24
jahre dauern bis daten von einem stern
bei uns eintreffen zitat ende
übrigens ist die nasa nicht alleine mit
ihrer idee mini raumschiff in unser
nachbar sternensystem zu schicken mit
dem projekt break schuster plant der
russische milliardär yuri milner
ähnliches auch hier soll an lasers einen
impuls auf eine weniges wenige gramm
schweres sonnensegel also ein englisches
anderes system wie bei der die berichten
und auch hier steckt philipp louven
dahinter wenn ihr in 54 jahren mehr über
die nachrichten auf einem anderen sterne
system erfahren wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen
nicht den auf die glocke denn nur dann
bekommt er eine die tv-nachrichten wenn
das video online geht hier geht es also
hier geht es weiter mit der reise zu
aliens nur 20 jahre zum nächsten stern
mit mehr infos zum projekt break star
schon sehr spannend und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran